different people at home is
um you know I know everything's online
now but if you can just sort of try to
evaluate random positions I find that's
a good way to increase your
understanding of Chess have a look at
random positions don't look at the
assessment the computer but try to work
out what's going on in that position so
really try to become a commentator for
for a little part of your day because
then you'll get to understand middle
game positions a lot more
um you know turn the computer on a bit
later on and what's going on here it's a
piece it is up for grabs
you know me grab it take it I want it
right yep okay black moves this Rook the
queen is nearly trapped but not quite
there's one safe square and now the
other Rook swings across Levon he's
gambling here he's just basically pushed
his chips into the center he's going all
in he wants to break through against the
white King again maybe good strategy
because he was struggling anyway he was
already in big trouble and now the white
king at least Magnus has to answer some
questions